you
hello everyone will come to Google cloud
on air live webinar from Google cloud
and we are hosting webinar sessions
every Tuesday my name is Morgan hey and
this is my colleague Harish today we
will be talking about how Credit Karma
improved a working efficiency SQL by
using the Google bigquery and a looker
dashboard you can answer crash or you
can ask a question anytime on the
platform and we have Google Earth
standby to answer at them let's get
started and market the analyst at Credit
Karma and this is Harish gaagaa hi this
is Harish Berger i'ma stop VI that is a
coma let me introduce Credit Karma for a
minute so Credit coma is a financial
technology company founded in 2007 best
known for providing credit score for
free for our 18 million members and we
can always provide the data-driven
insights and identify the 10
opportunities for our members and make
the most of their money whether someone
is interested in getting a better deal
on the loan like the credit card or
mortgage or simply just need to monitor
their identity or credit information we
can always provide the actionable tools
for them and help them make the
financial progress some quick stats
about Credit Karma and so just to
mention we have more than 18 millions
members in the US and Canada with that
been said if credit come up with the
country it will be the 16th largest
country in the world which is ahead of
Germany and there's around a 40 billion
dollar of credit originated through
Credit Karma
over the last ten years that's bigger
than the GDP of Kenya Jordan and Iceland
and they're around 20 million Americans
who have applied for a product like
credit card offers on Credit Karma
platform that's more people than were
born in the US over the last five years
and there's around half of the u.s.
Millennials use credit camera app that's
more than the number of Millennials who
watch Hulu or Amazon Prime as I
mentioned Credit Karma is highly
detailed written company we can always
provide the
actionable tools and help our members to
make the financial progress the so
Harish would you please introduce what's
data infrastructure looks like in the
past and a nowaday at Credit Karma
absolutely thanks Megan so before 2016
we had in-house columnar database and he
was spending a lot of time in in terms
of scalability and performance tuning
scalability in terms of they were keep
changing the dashboard database
configurations to support our data
database needs and they were also
spending a lot of time in hardware
maintenance and also the expensive
license renewal and on the performance
tuning side the queries performance was
really slow because most of them are
coming from the complex join on the
columnar database and it's delaying
overall our ETL processing time and
analytics team we were waiting for long
time to see them today data so we ran
with a lot of the POC and finally like
we found that bigquery was the best
database for us to support our business
needs so let me cover like what how did
our data stack looks like now
so from 2016 kirmada does take growth
from 30 terabytes and to the 1.8
petabytes and we collect nine terabytes
of data every day and we runs many model
prediction also so this is all about
volume but also we build meaning API
jobs which able to connect the various
different sources for example we are
connecting cell force for finance data
and we connecting Facebook for media and
Google AdWords for marketing nets and
like that there are other API jobs to
which we run own every day and land it
to the bigquery and do our look at
reporting on that on on the other side
of the other type of jobs which is like
mostly the machine learning models that
we're also running on the bigquery so we
for example if you want to forecast our
daily active users and if you want to
forecast like how many email you want to
send and what kind of offer we want to
send and if you want to predict our and
scoring rates so all these different
models also we are
so I would like to thanks Google and
their entire support team who really
helped us to brought to this position
and this also helped us in our
day-to-day business value now we have
like three different use cases which is
talked more about how we leverage a
bigquery on our day to day life so first
use case is daily active user forecast I
will let me run to drive this one thanks
Harish so name it define daily active
user for a second
so daily active user is a metric to
measure the number of members who come
to our site every day and it can be
reflected by the way we connect with our
members and also measured by the product
performance so a better deal active user
forecast model would allow our
stakeholders to monitor the product
performance in a very prompt way and we
use Google bigquery database to store
the model input and also the forecasted
result and then migrate the result from
the bigquery database to look at
dashboard so that our stakeholders can
monitor the performance and then compare
against actual daily active user on the
dashboard directly so in this way they
can improve the speed and quality of
their business decision for engaging
with our active users prior to the
current improved the data infrastructure
and the pipeline we have to train the
model manually every time we launch the
new initiatives so it cost a long
turnaround time for adjusting those
impact of the new initiatives and also
we have to collect the data from
different channel owners or
organizations which means it's hard for
us to unify the model input and then
produce the output very promptly for our
stakeholders because the data collection
is siloed it adds up the layer of
channel dependency on to the pipeline
and also human error might be involved
during the process so Harish would you
please tell us how business intelligence
team at Credit Karma solve those
challenges and improve the
infrastructure
absolutely we have automated data
pipeline system which connect our
expected email click ratios and actually
will click ratios and then we forecast
like how actual users going
perform on the email what we send on
this data pipeline we use the airflow
which is an open source tool from the
air BnB this is like for managing the
complex workflows and scheduling the
jobs first first thing is I'd love to
cover how we drive the expected email
click so in this our pipeline is first
reading the Google spreadsheet the
Google spreadsheet is we are running
through Python and that we that's made
the excel sheet is mostly maintained by
our campaign managers where they day to
day basis they're continuously updating
our expected email and push notification
click volume once the Python program
runs it connect its load that in our
back to the bigquery and then on the
other side we connect back to the
bigquery again for our actual data so
once we have our expected email and push
notification data and the actual email
and push notification data we combine
both this data and prepare our data set
for the model then we send this data
back to our machine learning model and
that machine learning model are trying
to predict the daily users how how they
want to take an email how they're going
to read those email how they're going to
perform over those emails right and then
we send this forecast number back to the
bigquery and ultimately then we connect
this looker to the bigquery to see the
overall performance on our daily
forecast thanks duration so because of
those improvement on the data pipeline
we got the chance to improve the
flexibility and robustness of our
forecast model just like the daily
active user forecast and also our
stakeholders can get a better and up to
the reports directly on the Luka
dashboard for their business planning
and they also can monitor the product
and the channel performance on the data
the lucra dashboard directly and it
improves the working efficiency a lot
and next her wish we'll talk about how
Credit Karma used machinery and tools to
improve the emo targeting efficiency yes
thanks big round so you know we are
trying here we are like in this
particular use case we are trying to
improve
overall the targeting efficiency on the
email notification so we before before
like before I proceed on the remainings
I let me talk more about what is model
driven email is motor driven email is is
a machine learning model where
especially we are looking for what kind
of offer users are searching for example
if they are looking for a credit card or
personal no non mortgage loan so based
on the requirement we predict the the
email we predict the users who most
likely tend to get those emails and who
also like you to open those emails and
click on those emails and then take the
offer promise I will cover the data pipe
in more in detail but I want to first
explain what are the challenges we had
before so these are the couple of points
here like we have huge amount of
variables to support so we have a tip a
tip million-plus members and there are
like thousand plus input variable it was
very difficult to and it was very
time-consuming a resource and tells you
to to collect all this data collection
you know like and then send those data
back to the model and then score and
then send you to users it was almost a
nightmare for us to run those huge
amount of data on the columnar database
and there was no manual check and they I
mean there were no quality checks also
in place and we we don't know like what
are the data anomaly we found over those
emails and variables like many variables
are coming with the coming with a blank
values or with they don't have any
values so there was no point in running
model on such values so it was very
difficult to identify such problem
without an automated pattern system we I
will talk more about like how we solve
those challenges we we again we use air
flow to to implement such end-to-end
pipeline this pipeline is help us to
collect the data over the all the users
who perform on the emails in the last
few months and we collect all those data
RNA scoring and then finally send out an
email so let me start with the more
little bit more detail at how
this pipeline works this pipeline is
actually works on the three models one
is the impression to click that means
that when we send out an email to our
users when they saw the email and they
click on that email that means
impression to click and the second model
is click to applications when they try
to click that click on the offers and
they try to fill all their information
on the partner side and then submit an
application and the third model is
approval once they submit an application
their application sent to our partners
and then partners make a decision
whether they get approval on their
offers or not so we in the first step in
the Google bigquery we tried to collect
all these three model data so for four
impression to click and a click to
application we collect those data points
from the user recent monetization
history like how they perform over the
email in the past few months and for the
approval model we rely on our online
recommendation system team where they
given us more idea about what are the
approval odds for our members so once we
collect all this three model data set we
run we run the queries and then we store
the data into the Google Cloud storage
that is for preparing the training data
set then once that data set is ready we
send those data back to the tensorflow
so tensorflow is helping us on this is
another like the cloud service we get
from the Google where like be able to
run our machine learning model or all
these three three data sets so this
model is actually scoring the every
members on the thousands of variables
just to make sure that we we we make a
right ranking on every members that what
offers they supposed to receive so this
scoring is calculated entirely through
this model and again store it back to
the bigquery so once we have our scoring
set ready now we want to drive this
chorong and now we want to try this our
scoring data set through through the
excel sheet so this excel sheet is it's
all about the campion sheet here we
maintain the different email campaigns
so our campaign managers come in and
they keep
adding the new campaigns and the
modifying the existing campaigns and
they change the behavior of this
campaign that means for example if I
want to send out an email to the users
who have a score between 600 or 700 with
the age band of 30 to 30 30 to 35 so
they change those criteria and they look
for that what offer we need to send to
those users so they select all those
criteria over those actual she'd our
pipeline we don't automatically read
this excel sheet and combine this
scoring data set together and then we
run our targeting queries in the
bigquery so this targeting queries are
all about figure it out like who are
eligible for sending out an email so
once we have this targeting queries
ready then we send this data back to the
Hartman's Hartman's is an internet tool
which allow us to send out an email to
our members with their specific openings
and harish would you please introduce
what hermit is quite a comma and how we
utilize Hermus to sends an email to our
targeting users
great question so Hermes is an internal
tool for the user level targeting where
we can allow marketing analysts to write
their own sequel query and decide the
range of the users whom they want to
send an email and what kind of offer
they want to filtered out serration
overall with this data pipeline itself a
lot is improve not just improve the
overall you know like efficiencies also
improve it help us to send out the right
offer to the users this helped us an
overall our engagement on the emails and
also it reduced the overall resources to
you know collect the data every time and
refresh refresh the data run the model
and send out up-to-date emails every
time so this whole automated system is
reduced lot of the main power and also
improve the overall data processing time
and also add a lot of value to our
business and we also have a looker who
pointing to those the email campaigns
data where we do the measurement check
that how each campaigns are performing
for example
if he if you send a chase card to the
particular members weather weather how
many members basically open those emails
how many of them click on that how many
of them take the offer from us so all
this we continuously drive on the luca
dashboards and the based on that we
going back and reengineering our the
entire data reengineering our model to
make sure that we have right data set
and we have right feature set to ensure
that we keep delivering the best the
email to our members as we can this is
really helpful because email is one of
our most efficient way of targeting our
users and also how we engage with our
users sending the more relevant message
with the right amount of frequency are
pretty critical to our business and next
Harish is gonna wrap up the our love to
use case how we obtained a better model
for user acquisition and a better offer
pricing on the search media absolutely
so this so this is a one of our under
views case where we are trying to
improve the overall the user engagement
and user experience of when they are
looking for in any offer on the paid
search and display media so we we had
like this how this work is we have a
Google return on adspend algorithm that
allow us to bid in auctions at the user
level granularity so we and this also
help us in overall quality of the new
user engagement based on their
monetization
so it's monetization is all about how
user click on the emails in the past and
how they took the offers over the over
the Google Ads and ultimately this
helped us to send a you know like
increase overall efficiency ins you know
like sending the overall revenue to the
CK and based on our target so there are
like before I explain more about how
this data pipe end works how we improve
the automated the ad campaigns the
features let me first explain what are
the challenges we had before why we why
we got the less traffic in the past over
our ads
and how we get the flat value on the
every transactions so we had this flat
to flat rate concept initially on the
every credit card application overheads
now this flat 2 flat value also means
that how how what kind of users us came
to came to the Google and take the offer
from us in the past and this this base
this this basis also is all about like
these user sets are coming from
different user segments like for example
they are coming with a different score
band and each band they are coming with
a specific platform like mobile or web
and then they are coming in the last 7
days or 10 days or any months or not and
it's also about coming they are coming
from the organic or display media are
not so based on this different media
searches and based on the overall this
mixed traffic we were defining the
average weight on the offers so this
average weight scoring was it was like
it was good for the campaign level
analytics but it was not good for the
user level scoring so ultimately like we
were getting the flat red for every
critical transitions that was actually
slowed down the overall ad revenue
growth and we also had a difficulty in
identifying the issues in the pipeline
for example when I talked about in the
earlier point how the different user
segments come in on the site and they
take the offer from us there was like
the issue where data is not normally
distributed and we were not sure that
what kind of volumes are coming and how
the data is coming and and ultimately we
are spending lot of money on our ad ad
campaigns so overall overall it was like
impacting our transition revenue on our
credit card applications on the ads so
this is how we solve the challenges we
build the data pipeline which is
automatically collect all the
user the history how they perform over
the Google ads we so V what so this is
like for example if users are coming
with a specific segments so we we make
sure that we collect all this data set
you know for a few months so what we did
is like we we went had in our database
in a big query and then we figure it out
like what are the user behaviors are for
example it's not all about five segment
is also about thousands of variable for
that given member how he actually came
to site at which time he came in from
where he came in and what kind of over
he were looking for not just not just on
the our website is also on overall on
the media and we collect all this data
points and then we store them in the
Google Cloud Storage and then we ran our
machine learning model to figure it out
that propensity of buying the offer from
from us so once we have this data set
ready we send it to back to the Google
the Google AdWords has this own
algorithm the the rows which is return
on adspend
that algorithm collect this data set and
that's run their own scoring on those
data set and then it's determined that
hey this is the users most tends to
likely take a offer this particular
offer from our ads and we ultimately
send all this data back to the bigquery
and then we have a looker again which is
connecting to the bigquery and see the
overall the performance like how these
things are happening like how many how
what kind of users are coming every day
what kind of offers they are looking for
and where we can improve more so
ultimately this helped us a lot
there was no manual work we
automatically our our bigquery is
automatically executing on a scheduled
basis they collect all the data points
on the user behavior and it
automatically sent to the Google AdWords
Google AdWords decide their own scoring
and target so it's it's it's a good
aligned with our incentive between the
bigquery and the Kurama data and it's
also I would say
it helped us like we it also helped us
in a way that it's use our proprietary
data and it makes our media channel more
profitable thanks to rich for amazing
presentation
so from analyst perspective is really
critical and also helpful for us to get
a better efficiency by using Google
cloud platform and the bakery as well as
UK dashboard just like these three
examples we can definitely reduce their
turnaround time for generating a
forecast model for our stakeholders and
we can get a higher and included email
targeting efficiency and we can also get
a better click to conversion ratio in a
very cost-effective way and I hope you
enjoyed this webinar session as much as
we did and stay tuned for the live Q&A
and we will be back in s in a minute
you
welcome back so let's get started with
some live questions so the first one
have you used a cloud dataflow for the
pipeline as well also are you doing this
on a real-time basis or a batch process
great question we have not used we have
done the Pierces on the dataflow but
yeah this is nothing we have put in a
production mostly we are using the data
proc and tensorflow
for our pipeline and yes and we are also
doing lot of in-house testing on the
real-time model building but currently
most of them are on the batch processing
do you have anything to optimize the
performance of bakery
yeah it's depend like what kind of query
you are running for if you are using the
legacy sequel query we definitely
encourage you to use the standard sequel
query and make sure that you keep all
your joints in mind and also depends on
what at what time you are running those
queries if you if you are having a
limited license and and you have for the
many analytics teams who using the
bigquery at the same time I would
recommend that use those heavy queries
in the in the batch in the badge of in
the night next question how does look
how to connect to yes so Luca Luca has a
so we can in the looker we can first
define the connection to the bakery on
their admin we have full control of
connecting to the any database and then
we have look ml feature where you just
need to import the bigquery table and it
automatically will the look ml for you
all you need to do is just simply
refresh that model and simply drag and
drop and start visualizing your data on
the bakery life next question what
advice would you give to someone who's
starting this process now yes that comes
with a lot of things for example depends
on what kind of infrastructure you have
what kind of instances you want to run
if you if you want to run like on on a
smaller data set it's fine you can spin
up the small GC pins
and then you can create your small
project and then you can start with a
limited license and you can continue to
go from there but again if it is coming
to the middle in a large-scale business
you have to decide again on the
architecture side that how many
instances you need how many projects you
need because you ultimately don't want
one project to create and everyone want
your company to you the same project
because of limited concurrent concurrent
query limit so you have to split those
project out and decide your organization
numbers like how many people who gonna
run the queries and what kind of queries
they wanna run if you organize it very
well then yeah of course this is like
perfect use case where you can
continuously use and continue scale your
instance over the cloud and keep running
your queries next one
so how up today is the data that can be
showing I'll look at dashboard so that
is also depend on like how you want to
refresh the data if you want to refresh
on the scheduled basis in the looker you
can always there is option where you can
create your derive sequel queries and
you can set a trigger alert for
automatically cache shall automatically
clear the cache so in that way if
someone go to the local dashboard it
will hit to that look ml
behind-the-scene it run that query and
automatically clear the cache for you
and show you up-to-date data and but
some time like people don't want to
create or sequel a doc sequel queries
because this comes with lot of
performance impact too so they can
always like always go to that a look at
dashboard there is option there and you
can go ahead and click on that clear
cache button and that will just simply
go and hit to the bigquery table and
give you up-to-date data on your
dashboard okay cool so next question
what made you decide to switch to
bigquery yeah this is what we something
discussed initially that we we it
depends like from where you are coming
from we came from the columnar database
system they come with a lot of the
maintenance issues and also the
performance issues because our ETL
queries are very heavy and their runs
terabytes of data every day and it's
really slowed down the performer
because of the complex joy and
ultimately our ETL was delaying and the
analytics teams not getting the data on
the right time so and also the it was a
lot of maintenance also and also cause
to the infrastructure also you know in
terms of Licensing renewal so if you
consider all this factor I mean Google
bigquery is the place where you can go
to the cloud you can spin distance so
quickly so easy to go there there are a
lot of features rightly available all
you just need to spin the instance you
create your project and you can always
scale that on demand basically you don't
need much interaction with any support
team or so because it's so
self-explanatory you can simply go ahead
and go to that instance and decide your
or could incur a limit define your own
cluster and start using the database
cool I think that's all the question we
got so thanks for joining us this
webinar session please stay tuned for
the next recession Google into a Google
cloud Internet of Things
from devices to cloud in their bellowing
business outcomes in a secure way thank
you thank you